in today's uncertain environment you
have to become a smarter
more responsive business who quickly
responds to market changes
this starts with unifying data and ai
tools and processes
to accelerate innovation and the ability
to predict and automate outcomes
so how do you make sure your business
has the ability to work with data
and derive trusted insights through ai
ibm cloud pack for data is a unified
data in ai platform
that's open extensible and available on
any
cloud or on-premises environment the
single solution helps you scale the
value of data
infuses ai throughout your business to
better predict and shape outcomes
and automates workflows to drastically
improve productivity
and outcomes for your teams and
customers now
let's break down what makes this
platform stand apart from others
first ibm cloudpack for data provides a
robust ecosystem
of services that can flexibly be
provisioned as your needs evolved
it consolidates best-in-class
capabilities across the end-to-end
ai life cycle into a single interface
for every member of your data teams to
collaborate in
from the it architect the data steward
the line of business to the data
scientist your teams can unite to easily
work with data and ai
needs second the platform can empower
your teams to predict
outcomes and intelligently automate
workflows for use cases
such as data modernization to help bring
you together
and work with any data type structure
quantity and speed across multi-cloud
environments
integrated data privacy and security
services
to help you automate the monitoring of
sensitive data to achieve compliance
data and ai governance tools to help you
manage the quality
compliance and trust in your ai across
your organization
for access to clean and complete data
self-service data ops
to provide a data pipeline through
capabilities such as
multi-cloud data integration data
cataloging
and data management increasing
findability and governance
modeloffs and ai lifecycle management to
help you synchronize
application and model development
throughout the entire ai life cycle
model risk management services to help
you combat
bias and ensure model fairness
and explainable ai for confident
and transparent decisions in your ai
models and outcomes
ai driven forecasting services from ibm
watson that provide pre-defined ai
workflows
for customer service and financial
business and it operations
for more accurate and timely forecasting
simply put ibm cloud pack for data
allows you to do more with your data on
your terms
in one place your business can now truly
be
intelligent resilient and flexible to
help you save future outcomes
take the step forward in unlocking the
intelligence
of your data and improving your business
outcomes
with ibm cloud pack for data a trusted
data and ai platform
for all your needs
you